المترجم: maissa njim
المدقّق: Riyad Almubarak
مرحبا
سأقدم نفسي أولا
اسمي "نجوى عوان"، 18 سنة
طالبة سنة ثانية رياضيات تطبيقية
وأيضا لاعبة تنس على الكرسي المتحرك
وبطلة المغرب لمدة عام
(تصفيق)
أحتل الرتبة 85 عالميا
اليوم سأحكي عن حياتي
التي قمت بتقسيمها لـ 4 أقسام
حياتي قبل الحادث
حياتي في الحادث
حياتي بعد الحادث،
في الوقت الذي قلت فيه "لقد انتهيت"
"كرهت حياتي"، "أتمنى الموت" إلخ إلخ
وحياتي بعد أن قررت أن أرفع رأسي
وعلمت أني أفضل من الناس العاديين
الذين يملكون رجلين ويدين
ولا يملكون دماغا
(تصفيق)
هذه الصورة من 2007
عندما كنت طبيعية
توجت بطلة سباق المسافة الطويلة "أسلان"
كنت أتعلم الرقص الشعبي أيضا
حلمي كان أن أكون بطلة رياضية يوما
أو راقصة. شكرا لله لم أصبح راقصة
عام 2008 يوم 27 يناير الساعة 16 تقريبا
كنت أتزلج على العجلات حين بدأ
كلب بيت بول يلاحقني وعضني من رجليَ
ألحقت بالمستشفى وأجريت
لي عملية ناجحة وعدت للمشي مجددا
بعد 12 شهرا لم أعد قادرة على المشي
أكثر من 10 امتار
ساقي أصبحت خضراء عندما أضعها على الأرض
وأعدت إجراء الفحوصات
تبين أن لدي رجل طبيعية
وأخرى لا يصلها الدم
دخلت المشفى مجددا وأجريت عملية أخرى
بسبب خطأ طبي وقيل لي أن كل شيء جيد.
خرجت من العملية دون ساق.
بعدها أجريت 10 عمليات تقريبا
أحدها كانت من الثامنة صباحا إلى الواحدة
ليلا تلقى فيها والدي خبر احتمالية موتي
كنت أعلم حينها إن حدث شيئا فيومها أو لا
لأني أحسست بوهن جسدي
تذكرت حينها كلام والدتي قالت
لي "أوعديني أني سأجدك حية غدا"
في الرابعة صباحا أجريت عملية أخرى،
لم ينقذوا ساقي ولكنهم أنقذوني
هذه كانت المرحلة الأولى من حياتي
عدت إلى المنزل كأي شخص عادي
في البداية قلت: "كل شيء على ما يرام
مادام هناك حياة هناك أمل، سأتأقلم"
أخذت وقتا لأدرك أني لم أعد أملك رجلين
خاصة في المدرسة عنما أرى أصدقائي يلعبون
وأنا أشاهد فقط
من هناك بدأت معاناتي
كنت أبكي كل ليلة في المنزل
وأصبحت حساسة جدا
سمعت الكثير من الكلام الجارح
"معاقة، عرجاء، لو كنت مكانك لانتحرت"
وكنت أبكي بسبب ذلك وأتمنى الموت
في سن 14 ذهبت إلى مختص صنع
الأطراف الاصطناعية لأستطلع عن الأمر
عندها لم أكن أحبذ الأطراف الصناعية لأني
لم أكن أريد أن أخفي حقيقتي أمام الناس
كان ذلك هو اليوم الذي غير حياتي
والفضل يعود إلى والدي والمختص
كان الأخير صاحب فكرة
خلق جمعية للمعاقين الرياضيين
في مجتمعنا المعاقون يتسولون في الشارع
أو يعتكفون في المنزل مختبئين
قام والدي بخلق الجمعية وكان لدينا
الاختيار بين رياضة التنس، أو السباحة
أو topend وهي رياضة العدو بالكرسي المتحرك
اخترنا التنس
كانت أول مرة أحمل فيها المضرب
في هذه الصورة
مدربنا باولو الجالس هناك وهو مدرب عالمي
قال يوما جملة غيرت حياتي
قال أن هذه الفتاة تملك الموهبة وأنها
ستصبح بطلة إذا زاولت التدريب
وبالضبط، أصبحت بطلة المغرب ولكن هدفي هو
المرتبة الأولى عالميا أو لا أسمي نفسي بطلة
أو أن أحتل مرتبة بين الخمس الأوائل عالميا
هذا وعد مني
قاطعت التدريب عامين لأني لم أعتبر
نفسي من المعاقين كالبقية
استأنفت مجددا وكنت أجد أعذارً للانقطاع
وهذا ما حدث
بعد التدريب لشهرين شاركت في بطولة المغرب
وكنت في المرتبة الأخيرة عندها
ربحت المرتبة الثالثة، عندها تذكرت ما قاله
مدربي باولو وزاولت التدريب
في البداية كنت أتدرب
عندما تسنح لي الفرصة، هذه الصورة بعد عامين
أصبح فيها تدريبي منتظما أكثر
وأصبحت بطلة المغرب
في العام الماضي شاركت في بطولة إفريقيا
ثم كأس العالم.
لم يكن مستواي مناسبا لكاس العالم وقتها.
حللت في المرتبة العاشرة.
بذلت ما في وسعي ولعبت بشكل محترم
أول مبارات أظن كانت مع صاحبة المركز 11
عندها لم أكن أملك ترتيبا عالميا.
لذلك كان إنجازا أفتخر به
في الختام أريد أن اقول إني اليوم قادرة
على أن أخرج من المنزل على الكرسي المتحرك
أو العكاز أو حتى الطرف الإصطناعي دون خجل.
الرسالة التي أردت أن أوصلها اليوم
أنه عندما ترى معاقا وتقول "مسكين"
ليس هو "المسكين" بل أنت.
وأن الحياة ليست متعلقة
بامتلاك الكمال الجسدي،
وأن أهم شيء هو امتلاك الدماغ.
وأيضا أن تنظر إلى الجانب المشرق من المشكلة
وليس فقط من الجانب المظلم.
عندها ستحس بالمعنى الحقيقي للسعادة
أفضل من ذاك الذي لم يواجه مشكلة في حياته
كنت دائما أقرأ مقطعا من قصيدة يقول "إن كنت
أستطيع العودة، كنت سأسلك نفس الطريق".
سابقا كنت أقول إني من المستحيل أن أقوم
بذلك، واليوم أقول لكم إن أوتيت الفرصة
لن أسلك نفس الطريق لأصبح بطلة العالم.
شكراً.
(تصفيق)